[Music]
one thing you can't avoid here in New
York are the pedicabs they are
everywhere and tourists love sightseeing
in them and they've really sprout in the
last couple of years they're just
everywhere I wanted to find out what
it's like to be a pedicab driver in New
York I got a camera crew here's what
happened this is Heidi and Heidi this is
your pedicab is that right yes what are
the things I need to know if I'm a
pedicab driver hi Ryder
first of all don't hit anyone don't hit
anyone okay follow traffic follow
traffic be polite not so much sounds
like Harpo Marx is coming who would a
SAP tourists what kind of nationality
should I go after which I bet the Dutch
the Dutch you just like I would like to
go and yeah and you could just charge
them anything right within reason
you think I'm up to the challenge I
could do it I'm 48 years old I think if
you do it okay
I'm 27 so I think I'm okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello would you like a ride you ladies
wanna lift
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you guys have families what's going on
you got a husband is he gonna be mad
when he sees you hitting what's-his-name
hey Chris Maria's slapping my butt and I
said you married he said yeah so says
your husband gonna be mad he says he's
okay so you don't see me as a sexual
threat at all
[Music]
how are you
right come on over all right
my name is Cohn and I'll be your tour
guide over here this is Central Park
it's filled with trees and urine that's
all History Museum up here
what else are fun facts do I have Mayor
Bloomberg is a crossdresser
not many people know that that's where
my wife's boyfriend lives she thinks I
don't know but I found out I hate that
guy weird is it yes that's me hello go
get your graduations in yeah this is
what I'm doing now it says I was join
spires deep right now in your pedicab
driver
have a seat
these things oh I've been doing this for
about three years now yeah I got a show
and then it kind of blow up and I've
been here in the city huge in Finland
hi big star in Finland how far you going
hundred bird let's play Florida Colette
it's pretty far
[Music]
good way to see the city